We are very quickly seeing a sort of fork in
the Republican Party where some Republicans
are doubling down on Trump, people like
Lindsey Graham, who says he's headed down
to play golf with Trump in the next week. Kevin
McCarthy, who we just spoke about, who, despite a
angry phone confrontation with Trump on January
6th, flew down to Florida to recruit Trump's help
in winning the house back in twenty. You've got
those people, but then you have other Republicans
who are sometimes overtly, sometimes a little
more covertly distancing from Donald Trump. Mitch
McConnell was an incredible example of this in his
speech moments after the acquittal of Donald Trump
in his second impeachment trial this weekend,
which we already discussed. Another interesting
one is Republican Nikki Haley. Haley was the
governor of South Carolina. She later was Donald
Trump's ambassador to the United Nations. She's
completely abandoning Donald Trump now. And she
says Trump, quote, let us down and that we, quote,
shouldn't have followed him. This is arguably
the most direct and forceful rebuke of Trump from
strictly political figures that worked for Trump.
We've seen lots of rebukes from secretaries and
folks who had more concrete roles. Trump's former
secretary of state. Trump's former secretary of
defense, Trump's former national security adviser,
John Bolton, but this is different when it's
Nikki Haley. Nikki Haley's interview with
Politico was published going into this weekend,
and it's quite stunning. She pulls no punches.
Let's look at some quotes. Some of these are from
different parts of the interview. She says, quote,
He's not going to run for federal office again.
I don't think he's going to be in the picture. I
don't think he can. He's fallen so far. She
says we need to acknowledge he let us down.
He went down a path he shouldn't have and we
shouldn't have followed him and we shouldn't
have listened to him. And we can't let that ever
happen again. When I tell you I'm angry, it's an
understatement. Mike Pence has been nothing but
loyal to that man. He's been nothing but a good
friend of that man. I am so disappointed in the
fact that despite the loyalty and friendship he
had with Mike Pence, that he would do that to
him like I'm disgusted by it. And lastly, Nikki
Haley saying I think he's going to find himself
further and further isolated. I think his business
is suffering at this point. I think he's lost any
sort of political viability he was going to have.
I think he's lost his social media, which meant
the world to him. I mean, I think he's lost the
things that really could have kept him moving.
Now I want to repeat once again. This is really
important about our analysis of what Nikki Haley
and others have been saying, these quotes aren't
about realizing Nikki Haley. She gets it now.
She gets she really gets it. Not at all. These
people are responsible for Trump in various ways.
First of all, in general, Republicans for decades
radicalize the party more and more so that Trump
was then able to run and win in 2016, never would
have been able to win a Democratic primary. But
they also worked for him despite knowing this
and this has always been Trump. Nikki went and
was ambassador to the United Nations for Trump,
despite all the things we knew about Trump.
So this is not an analysis of people having
an awakening and all of that stuff. And these
are good Republicans. This is a story about a
Republican Party that is currently pulling itself
apart or maybe is going to pull itself apart. Some
newcomers are riding the Trump wave, Marjorie
Taylor Greene, Lauren Bobert, Madison, Cawthorn
and others. Some long timers are just sticking
with Trump. Like Lindsey Graham. Some long timers
seem to be distancing from Trump
like Mitch McConnell and others.
And then you've got people that were never really
with Trump, Mitt Romney. He thought maybe he could
be Trump's secretary of state. He went and had
turtle soup and frogs legs with Trump early on,
but has basically a distance from Trump years
and years ago. Nikki Haley wants a continued
political career. She's young. She's only forty
nine compared to some of these guys in their 70s
and 80s. She wants to wash herself of the stink
of Trump. So now she's going through this process.
And what we're learning here is quite simply,
they knew all along what Trump was. They merely
pretended not to know when Trump was their
ride to notoriety or a position of power
or a position of prestige. They are even
more immoral than we thought because they
weren't even tricked by Trump. If they were
really tricked, we could say they're dumb,
but they're less immoral. They weren't tricked.
They looked away deliberately. They knew all
along what it was. And they want I mean, look at
Chris Christie. Remember Chris Christie denouncing
Trump endlessly during the primary in which he
ran and Lindsey Graham, too, by the way, then
standing behind Trump, figuratively and literally.
Remember the video of Chris Christie standing
behind Trump looking like he ate a bad oyster
and saying, yeah, Trump, Trump, I'm with Trump.
And then eventually Chris Christie starting
to make a little more sense on Trump over the
last six months or so. He knew all along it was
just a calculation. How much power can I grab
by attaching myself to what was then the
rising star of Trump? They all knew all
along. And none of them deserve to be forgiven.
But from a practical perspective, it does raise
questions about the future of the Republican
Party, which we will continue to talk about.